A shark movie without any bite? "Meg 2:
The Trench" isn't making a splash with Rotten
Tomatoes critics for some surprising reasons.
In 2018, director Jon Turteltaub surprised
audiences with his kinetic and intriguing
"The Meg." Based on Steve Alten's novel of
the same name, the film follows a megalodon
that pesters a group of scientists and
a very exhausted Jason Statham. While it
was far from perfect, "The Meg" was good
summer fun, giving viewers a compelling,
action-heavy journey through the depths
of the ocean. In a landscape littered with
superhero flicks and reboots, "The Meg" was a
breath of fresh blockbuster air that featured
an all-star cast and a competent narrative
about big sharks. What else could anyone want?
Audiences around the world were receptive
to Turteltaub's nightmarish shark flick,
helping "The Meg" gross over $500 million at
the global box office. After proving itself as a
global financial success, it wasn't surprising to
hear that Warner Bros. was interested in a sequel.
"Jonas, we've got nothing left."
"Almost nothing."
Ben Wheatley, the auteur behind "Free Fire"
and "Kill List," was brought on board to helm
the sequel. Seeing as Wheatley had never helmed a
large, big-budget blockbuster before, having the
British director steer the "Meg 2: The Trench"
ship felt like an inspiring decision. Could
Wheatley turn a potentially bloated sequel into a
genuine, pulse-pounding work of deep sea horror?
Eh, doesn't look like it. Rotten
Tomatoes critics were the first to
see Wheatley's "Meg 2: The Trench"
and they're not very enthusiastic
about it. IGN critic Matt Donato was not
impressed with the film at all, writing:
"'Meg 2: The Trench' has all the excitement of
fishing solo for two hours without a single bite."
Ouch. Rotten Tomatoes critics were
surprisingly disappointed with how "Meg 2:
The Trench" is occupied with elevating
itself instead of fully leaning into
its insane premise. Graeme Tuckett of Stuff wrote:
"'Meg 2' is burdened with an actual plot. [...]
The sharks barely show up. And when they do,
they are such clearly CGI creations, it really
does look as though Statham and chums are being
attacked by characters from an animation
that have stumbled into the wrong film."
Deadline wasn't impressed with the
sci-fi aquatic sequel either, saying,
"At several points along the way you could
bang your hand to your forehead in reaction
to how random and non-transporting the action
is, even when there's a great deal of it."
"This was a bad idea."
"Just a little bit."
Well, a movie about giant sharks certainly
won't appeal to everyone. Is the film fun
at least? CinemaBlend's Eric Eisenberg was
particularly disappointed in the film, saying,
"'Meg 2: The Trench' wants to just be
seen as dumb fun, but it doesn't earn it."
Clearly, most of the critics who took to
Rotten Tomatoes before the film's release
weren't fans of "Meg 2." Some critics went
ahead and even labeled the film as boring,
perhaps the worst assessment
any project can receive.
But despite the mediocre reviews, "Meg 2: The
Trench" still has some fans in its sunken corner.
Calum Marsh of The New York Times had a
few positive sentiments about the film,
saying that the sequel features a "a spark of
wit" that fits in effortlessly with its narrative.
Katie Walsh of the St. Louis Post Dispatch
also acknowledged the film's shortcomings but
couldn't help but come around to Wheatley's
chaotic vision as it wrapped up, writing:
"About halfway through 'Meg 2: The Trench,'
this self-serious sequel suddenly becomes
funny, [...] leaning into the slippery
silliness of a summer shark flick."
Liz Shannon Miller of Consequence put it bluntly,
reminding viewers that this is ultimately
a movie about giant sharks, saying:
"['Meg 2: The Trench' is] a far more
coherent entry in the genre than others,
with effects work that's
several notches above the rest."
While most Rotten Tomatoes critics
are sour on the "Meg" sequel,
there are a few that find the film
compelling enough. Will these mixed to
negative reviews impact the film's
box office? Only time will tell.